cardi B hilariously co-hosts The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon I'll go in at all
until I give birth you're pregnant which
is the best news of all news
congratulations
what are you doing it how are you doing
it on how are you even doing how are you
functioning you know what I don't know
if it's the strength of the fetus but I
have never feel so hungry to succeed yes
just days after announcing she's
expecting her first child with Beyonce
upset the 25 year old rapper pulled
double duty on Mondays Tonight Show not
only co-hosting alongside Jimmy but
performing to cardi rocked a skin-tight
black latex bodysuit draped in gold
chains her growing bump on full display
[Music]
possibly the most interesting moment of
the night
cardi revealing to Jimmy if she had the
option she would have kept her pregnancy
under wraps I never really wanted to
review that I had a baby I just wanted
hide it to be in a day all day I could
have gotten away believe us so for the
many popular
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]